In order for us to calculate how many cycles it takes for the amplitude to decay
to one half its original value, we need to know the relationship between the amplitude
and the energy value which we know decays by 20.6% per cycle.
This relationship is actually given by the potential energy equation.
When the spring is most compressed or most extended,
then the displacement away from the equilibrium length is equal to the amplitude A.
At this point, where the spring is most stretched or most compressed,
the potential energy is exactly equal to 1/2KA².
We should be careful here the value here should not actually be K,
it should be equal to 4K, so this equation should actually be equal to 2KA²,
and that's because we have four springs down here which could be effectively treated as one spring
with a spring constant of 4K which we saw in the solution to the previous question.
Now, I'm going to substitute this value for potential energy 2KA²
and the value for energy in our earlier equation, and doing a little math,
we get that the current A² is equal to 0.794ⁿA².
Now, let's remember what we're looking for.
We are looking for the amplitude A that's equal to exactly half the original amplitude.
We can substitute one half A₀ for A here, and that gives us this equation here
and quite nicely, the A₀ terms cancel and that gives us this interesting equation up here that 1/4=0.794ⁿ
and depending on how much math you've had, you may recognize
that you can solve this equation by using something called a logarithm.
We don't actually have to use logarithms here.
It turns out that if you go through trying different values for ⁿ--different integer values in particular,
you'll find pretty soon that the solution to this equation actually is n=6,
This means it takes six cycles, six complete oscillations in order for the amplitude
of our spring oscillations to decay to one half the original value.
Great work if you got this problem, but if you didn't,
don't worry about it either--this was quite challenging.